let's bring in somebody live on the
couch it's great to have senator i don't
know if this is live but i'm here you
are live if you are watching
the united nations is here first off on
the border crisis you said there's one
thing we could do right now
well everybody's coming to seek asylum
if you said you can't apply for asylum
in the united states we no longer accept
asylum claims inside the country that
all stopped coming trump did that and it
went to a 45-year old country you're in
yeah okay if you're from the triangle
countries you have to apply there yep if
you come from some other place we send
you back to mexico you sit in mexico you
make your application you can't come
here to your hearing which is three or
four years down the road it would all
stop overnight nobody's going to pay a
bunch of money to sit in mexico for five
years yeah no kidding um
we were
chatting in the green room briefly and
you were kind of recounting everything
that's going haywire i want you to look
at a tweet from an associated press
reporter at the white house by the name
of jonathan lemire he tweeted out
yesterday the pentagon admitted its
errant drone strike coveted boosters did
not get full approval france recalled
the ambassador the punishing headlines
all within an hour on friday underscored
the perils for a president from
uncontrollable events that can define a
term were these uncontrollable events or
was this all just kind of bad strategery
from the biden people he chose poorly at
every turn if he had done nothing on the
border would be okay
he changed the remaining mexico policy
he did away with the asylum agreements
with the triangle countries guess what
we're overrun like the border patrol
told the transition team of biden
in december and january if he had left
the troops at bagram never closed bagram
air base we wouldn't have the taliban in
charge if you keep spending money like
this we're going to have inflation
through the roof so all this is
self-inflicted but there's a perfect
storm brewing guys the chaos in the
mideast is going to come to us here at
home through the border if we don't
change soon
just how easy would it be for a
terrorist group
to hire some cartel to take them into
the united states to the southern border
get in the middle of this humanity
like the haitians they're not sending
haitians back they're sending men back
and the women and children are staying
so nothing changes until you change our
asylum law but i'm really worried
about the narrative out there that
america was defeated in afghanistan
every jihadist is going to afghanistan
and there will soon be an effort to
infiltrate this country through the
southern border if we don't do something
about it it's a matter of time a matter
of time and time is running out the
chatter and i don't want to scare people
the chatter is real
i mean they're winning are you talking
about stuff you hear because you're
secretly
it's not so much
we hear things that the average person
doesn't but the chatter out there is
really real al qaeda
and the taliban are one in the same
they'll be an effort to normalize
relationships with the taliban that will
be a disaster any money you pay them
doesn't go to the people of afghanistan
it goes to them and they will give safe
haven to al-qaeda because they bleed the
same they have a common purpose what's
your reaction to the fact that we still
have individuals there we have not only
our allies but we do have americans
there they're saying maybe a hundred
i've heard 100 200.
exactly well my reaction is this was
self-inflicted that if you left the
military in country and got all the
civilians out first like a normal person
you wouldn't have this problem who in
the world takes all the military out
then hope you can get the civilians out
later this is a case study and just
screwing up
how to withdraw from a country bob
woodward book says that millie
as well as his
his secretary of state right as well as
the secretary of defense all recommended
he did not pull out all the troops
especially that way he said i appreciate
it i listened but i'm doing it my way
well president is that true from you
know so so this is really important
everybody in his circle said leave a
residual force lead the 2500 keep bagram
it's an insurance policy against another
911. it was joe biden and joe biden
alone who decided to pull all the troops
out trump told me last couple of nights
ago he had kept bagram if you'd kept
bagram in the cia post and along the
border the taliban could never take over
and al qaeda wouldn't come storming back
like they are today so this is general
biden knowing more than all the generals
combined he was told by everybody leave
a residual force it was his decision to
pull the plug just like it was in iraq
with him and about obama
some more bad news from the white house
i believe it was
sunday night when the parliamentarian
for your group the senate said you know
what uh the democrats god bless their
hearts uh trying to do this but you
cannot insert uh migra migration control
or immigration into the reconciliation
thing just can't do it uh they're
there's kind of
the way the rules are set up
so now the democrats are going to plan b
what's that going to look like
nobody's more happy about this ruling
than the democrats
if you actually put daca legalization in
a reconciliation
package where you only need 50
democratic votes they would own
legalizing
probably a million people can you
imagine the run on the border word get
out tomorrow hey they just give a
million people legal status
hurry on down right i believe would be
eight to 10 million they were talking
about legalizing illegals if you
legalize one person before you secure
the border and reform a broken
immigration system the run on the border
will be worse than it is today
the 3.5 is it dead
uh it depends on cradle to grave social
programs from
part of it i think i think at most
they'll do a trillion a trillion and a
half the 3.5 billion package is written
is dead it's an inflation bomb i talked
to manchin a couple of nights ago
he told me and i don't know if this is
accurate that we spent more money since
the onset of covid uh to deal with covet
than we did to win world war ii and the
marshall plan if that's true then we
need to slow down because we're going to
create inflation uh for decades to come
here if we don't watch it because people
people are feeling that with the high
prices
what do you know about how are we
getting our people back from afghanistan
are we negotiating with the taliban
this is the ultimate question we need to
have a hearing about what relationship
we have with the afghanistan okay how do
you get on the plane 28 americans got on
a plane from afghanistan to qatar thank
you to the
qataris
what system is in play
to get you on that plane why do you get
on and somebody else doesn't are we
paying money to the taliban i want to
know the system that's in place to get
our people out and what are we doing
about the thousands of afghan
interpreters translators and fighters
who fought along our side so my fear is
that taliban are milking us dry that
they're letting out small groups over a
long period of time to have leverage
over us and i'd like to turn it on them
i'd like to say you got 30 days to get
all of our people out or else wow that's
uh fascinating to find out because
we know we're about to write a check for
64 million dollars for humanitarian aid
who greenlighted that don't they have to
check with you before they give aid out
to a terrorist regime so all of us a
bunch of republicans have bills that say
not a penny for the taliban the world
food program people are starving in
afghanistan the economy has collapsed i
don't mind helping individual afghans
but i don't want to give a dime to the
taliban the taliban
are in fact the benefactor of al qaeda
we got attacked once when they were in
charge we're going to get attacked twice
if we don't the second time if we don't
watch it and isis is coming after them
15 approval rating by the taliban how do
they run this country they want so if we
prop them up it'll be the biggest
mistake since the withdrawal the last
thing you want to do is provide aid in
comfort american taxpayer dollars to
keep a terrorist group in charge of
afghanistan who paved the way for the
first 911 and that's what biden's about
to do they're about to create a
relationship between the united states
and the western world will we prop up
the taliban and we will live to regret
that all right senator lindsey graham
great to have somebody good morning
these are the issues is this uh
what's going on there's something better
i just don't know what it is
as you started you said it's a big mess
and gives us plenty to talk about well
this month we'll find out if there is a
biden agenda all right thank you sir